et là c'est beaucoup moins drôle que je
vous annonce puisque à ça s'est passé
hier céline dion a annoncé alors on
savait qu'elle ait annulé sa tournée
américaine mais la tournée européenne et
france restait et bien il vient
d'annoncer celle d'annoncer qu'elle
annulait également regarder ça en deux
fois alors de l'arrêt du mondial des
calmes on va décaler le décale disant
qu'elle lesquels à 56 ans il ya un
moment on ira voir son père lachaise
regardez-le annonce
et bien oui nous y voici encore
je suis tellement
désolé et attristé
d'être obligé de repousser les
spectacles une fois de plus
la première fois c'était évidemment
cause la pandémie
et cette fois ci c'est ma santé qui
m'oblige à reporter les spectacles de la
tournée européenne
et malheureusement d'en
annuler certains autres
je fais du mieux que je peux pour
reprendre la forme dès que possible
alors il ya une deuxième vidéo qu'elle
fait qui est beaucoup moins drôle où
elle parle de ses problèmes de santé
étaient rappelez-vous dans paris match
on l'avait vu il a jugé sérieux très
amaigrie la
lld soccer qui viennent donc elle a pris
un peu de poids et elle parle donc de sa
maladie je me sens quand même un peu
mieux
mais c'est sûr que ça va pas assez vite
et c'est super frustrant pour moi
mes médecins me suivait je reçois des
traitements mais j'ai toujours des
spasmes musculaires
la récupération prend beaucoup plus de
temps que je pensais
mais je me dois d'être en pleine forme
en pleine santé
pour que je puisse donner 100% de
moi-même sur la scène car c'est ce que
vous méritez
voilà et elle a décalé les dates à 2020
c'est à dire ce que je vais dire là elle
pensait pourquoi on n'y croit jamais
on y croit jamais on est toujours là
présent mais il a raison
elle a décalé pour 2023 2024 et pas très
bon signe là où je te rejoins laurent
c'est que que ce soit même la mort de
son mari autant souviens je vous raconte
cannes ou la mort de son mari lorsqu'il
était à l'église qui sort de l'église
donc tout était mise en scène y avait
des caméras il y avait des petits
stickers au sol pour qu'elle s'arrête à
un endroit très précis pour les caméras
et tout ça tout est mis en scène on est
mon ami mais c'est tout et chaud en
permanence et même quand elle finalement
je te rejoins laurent s'est fait manière
showtime américains disent qu'elle dise
quelque chose de positif qu'elle dise
quelque chose de triste il ya toujours
ce schéma avec des époques
métro
javel travers avec des expressions
complètement farfelu dépose des
ministères menace est là comme à
l'américaine alors vous savez qu on
aurait pu ou pas c'est très drôle on
arrête vous fassiez la même vidéo en
anglais mot pour mot et les mêmes poses
avec d'autres pas je la raconte
rapidement je vais à vegas et je vais la
voir chanter alors elle chante en
anglais qu en anglais qu en anglais et
tout d'un coup elle chante une chanson
en français ne me quitte pas il dit
maintenant je vais vous chanter un me
quitte pas de jacques brel c'est une
chanson qui me touche tellement
tellement tellement que je peux aussi je
pourrais aller au bout quand lille etc
si je peux pas je suis vraiment désolé
mais j'aurais tenté
ne me quitte pas de kit vous dis merci
et alors au bout d'une minute trente
précisé le fait ne me quitte pas à eilat
sur tourner elle pleure lumière noire
elle s'arrête et elle revient le départ
dont j'ai pas pu aller au bout bon très
bien c'est très touchant deux jours
après manque de bonnes je suis invité
par valérie michelin qui étaient là bas
et qui me dit ben vient la voir je suis
pas lui
jour je meurs fait le show et tout d'un
coup et maintenant je vais tenter de
chanter ne me quitte pas j'espère
vraiment que je vais aller au bout parce
que c'est une chanson qui est vraiment
touché à tous un tee shirt pour moi fait
que je me demander si elle me fait ne me
quitte pas et à une trente deux piles ne
me quitte pas hélas hélas
[Applaudissements]
tu te dis cette mecque tous tes fake non
mais c'est vrai toutes ces émotions à
l'enterrement de son mari elle était pas
vraiment traité
fiscalité dit qu'il sentait de permet de
lui quand on analyse le problème apple
fond on peut quand même avoir un gros
gros doutes sur le timing c'est à dire
que on sait tous cas des grosses
d'assurance derrière sur ses concerts là
c'est pas possible mais il ya une telle
annulation à un mois du début des
hostilités dans en angleterre dans toute
l'europe c'est impossible franchement
c'est moi si j'étais fallait rater ça
qui paraissait bien
pardon la productrice jackie
lombard c'est elle qui l'a qu'il a
tellement dit la vérité oui on a senti
la pression qu'elle est qu'elle est
déprimé certes des primes maladie sur
ses panoramiques et qui permet de faire
rembourser des concerts mais
assurent-ils faut une vraie maladie que
soient physiques une certifié par des
maîtres s'extraire je crois pas qu aux
etats unis la dépression compte pour
aller n'est là quand il faut sa classe
et pas annuler ses repartez doré gens
confie l'envié ça fait rappelle que le
carrière c'est jusqu'à 1000 $ à bien
s'il arrêtait décalé jusqu'en 2024 oui
enfin fou comme un bonbon c'est je pense
pas que leur dis attendez de 1024 a64 25
mars est moins remboursé reprennent leur
billet après abba non mais non
on doit dépenser pas contre un tel débat
mon téléphone et j'ai complètement ah
c'est vrai awek ont pas passer ça
commence à se corser en vue concernant
ce que je pense c'est qu'à la chaux côté
sincère archiac de dire exactement
quelle est pas du tout apte à assurer
des concerts donc je te dire je trouve
ça honnête de sa part et ce afin
de reporter de reporter des concerts
c'est pas assez pas c'est pas une fin en
soi quoi
simplement
dans les loges notamment sur les prêts à
oui ça c'est sûr il faut assurer des
concerts ce que je voudrais pas être des
banques via bord
j'ai énormément d'admiration pour toi
énormément comment pardon match et il
entend diviser vraiment formidable mais
il faut être un petit peu de mesure dans
d autres noms mais je n'ai effectivement
était une personnalité s'effectuera
bienveillant et gentil c'est gentil
c'est ce qu'ils font
[Applaudissements]